Speaker 1: Let's go next
to let's go to Brendan from
Jersey. Is it Brendan or Brenda? It's cut off.
Speaker 4: Oh, it's fine. It's Brendan.
Speaker 1: Brendan. Okay, welcome.
Speaker 4: Thanks for taking my call.
So my two topics for a question would be a
2024 question for the Dems and a question
about economics that could be agreed upon.
Speaker 3: By both sides. Okay. Which which of
those would you think would be more interesting?
Speaker 1: Let's do economics.
Speaker 4: So the first one would be with the
development of AI and robotics and lack of
general skilled labor. Trending over time, is it
time to properly incentivize, de-stigmatize and
promote vocational schools for skills.
Speaker 3: And trade development,
things like that?
Speaker 1: 100%. I mean, listen, I don't
I'm not someone who just says college is
for everyone. College doesn't have to be for
everyone. And in fact, I think the statistics are
that most people still don't don't go to college.
There's a couple different things.
One, if everyone has a college degree,
the college degree is no longer a filter
for certain jobs, and then you just need
something else. Is it now graduate school? Is
it whatever? So. So in one sense, college can
be the right path for some jobs and other paths
make sense for other jobs. In addition to that,
particularly if we are going to see the
technological change and advances that
we see in energy, in fabrication, in materials
sciences, all these different things. We want as
many people as possible. We need way more people
getting involved in the trades in order to be
ready for those coming changes and to get younger
people. A lot of these trades skew significantly
older and it's great now that there's a young
electrician movement, there's a young plumbing
movement and all these other things. They're going
to fix this problem of having to flush toilets 10
to 15 times. I know that the young people are
going to be able to do it. But yeah, I mean,
listen, a lot of those jobs pay really well.
They are great opportunities. And when we talk
about making education more affordable, when we
talk about student loans, when we talk all these
are things we should be talking about trades
just as much as we're talking about, you know,
traditional four year bachelor's degrees, 100%.
Speaker 4: Cool. Thanks. I was just going to say,
like with something like this, be agreed upon
by people on both sides of the political aisle.
And so if a candidate were to just develop
this as part of their platform, would that,
you know, potentially garner them more support?
Speaker 1: I think so. The problem is just saying
let's let's pump up trade school wouldn't
be enough for either side. And so if you're
on the left and you go, let's pump up trade
school and do some student loan forgiveness,
then the right will say, well, well, well, we
can't do the student loan forgiveness. So I
think that one part would have significant appeal.
But the question is what else is part of it? And
that's where the disagreements would start.
Speaker 3: Right. Right. All right.
Speaker 4: Well, I have another
question, but if you're good, I'm good.
Speaker 1: David, thank you. Yeah, thank you so
much. We'll get to the next question next time
since we have lots of folks
wanting to wanting to get in here.